oui alors que les tensions redescendre
d'un cran dans cette crise ukrainienne
les députés russes de la douma ont voté
un appel au président vladimir poutine
pour qu'il reconnaisse l'indépendance
des républiques autoproclamées du
dombass et ados nièce est lougansk une
proposition condamné par la diplomatie
européenne de son côté venir poutine a
réagi sur le sujet ont fait le point
avec notre envoyé spécial antoine
claireaux à donetsk les autorités de la
république autoproclamée de données se
félicite de la proposition des députés
russes qui invite vladimir poutine à
reconnaître les deux républiques
populaires du dôme bas sont tant qu'etat
indépendant et souverain et pour le
dirigeant de la rpdc le fait que
l'ukraine accroît sa présence militaire
le long de la ligne de contact signifie
que kiev n'a pas l'intention de
respecter les accords de kiev nie de
résoudre le conflit de façon pacifique
il estime donc que la voie vers une
reconnaissance peut désormais être
ouverte le discours à la douma d'état
avant le vote était très révélateur ils
ont montré à quel point les
parlementaires prennent à coeur les
problèmes des habitants du donbass à
quel point ils compatissent à tout ce
qui se passe dans les républiques à quel
point ils sont préoccupés par la menace
existante émanant de l'ukraine et de
l'occident nous remercions les députés
de la douma d'état pour les résultats du
vote d'aujourd'hui dans le même temps
nous traiterons toute décision des hauts
dirigeants de la fédération de russie
avec compréhension et respect dans ses
derniers mots sont toutefois la prudence
des propos du dirigeant de la rpdc bien
lui en a pris car en effet vladimir
poutine a réagi sur ce sujet c'était
lors de sa conférence de presse commune
avec le chancelier allemand nous
partirons du principe que
il faut faire pour que
le problème du dôme bas soit résolu mais
il faut le faire comme l'a dit monsieur
le chancelier fédéral avant tout
sur la base des
possibilités des accords de minsk qui
n'ont pas encore été mises en oeuvre en
espérant que nos partenaires
outre atlantique et en europe c'est à
dire la france et l'allemagne pourront
exercer une influence suffisante sur les
autorités de kiev pour qu' une solution
ce sens soit adopté les autorités
locales ici dans le donbass sont à
l'affût de toute solution politique qui
pourrait améliorer le sort de la
population mais pour l'exécutif russe la
voie diplomatique c'est à dire
l'application stricte des accords de
minsk reste la seule alternative viable
pour mettre un terme au conflit dans le
donbass d'autant que la reconnaissance
par moscou des deux territoires celui de
donetsk est celui de lougansk serait
particulièrement mal vus sur la scène
internationale pour paris cela
s'apparenterait par exemple à une
agression sans armes